una cafetería de la ciudad de mexico se
dedica a vender café importado el café
hondureño se vende a 80 pesos por
kilogramo lo que este dato nos va a
servir así que déjenme subrayar do el
café hondureño se vende a 80 pesos por
kilogramo bien mientras que el café de
costa rica se vende a 115 pesos por
kilogramo esto lo voy a tomar con color
azul entonces el café de costa rica se
vende a 115 pesos por kilogramo muy bien
si la mezcla de café de américa central
contiene 0.4 kilogramos de café de costa
rica y 0.6 kilogramos de café de
honduras eso vamos a ponerlo el café de
costa rica es 0.4 kilogramos muy bien
mientras que en el café de honduras es
0.6 kilogramos y con estos dos se hace
la mezcla de américa central juntan
estos dos cafés y hacen una nueva mezcla
de café la pregunta es cuánto debe de
costar el programa de la mezcla de café
de américa central y bueno esencialmente
lo que nos pide esta pregunta
es saber cuánto cuesta 0.4 kilogramos de
café de costa rica si sabemos que el
kilogramo se vende a 115 pesos y cuánto
vale 0.6 kilogramos de café de honduras
de igual manera si sabemos que el
kilogramo se vende a 80 pesos para así
hacer la mezcla de américa central
entonces se voy a hacer la mezcla de
américa central primero que fijarnos qué
es lo que necesitamos del café de costa
rica entonces déjame ponerlo aquí el
café de costa rica para saber qué pasa
con el café de costa rica lo primero que
voy a recordar es cuánto cuesta el café
de costa rica dice que cuesta 115 pesos
por kilogramo
entonces déjenme apuntarlo aquí el café
de costa rica valen 115 pesos por
kilogramo esto es por kilogramo muy bien
pero del café de costa rica voy a
utilizar solamente 0.4 kilogramos del
café de costa rica por lo tanto ni
siquiera muy llegar al kilogramo voy a
necesitar solamente
punto 4 kilogramos y bueno lo voy a
multiplicar de tal manera que el
kilogramo con kilogramos se va a ir y
solamente me quedan 0.4 por 115 que es
lo mismo que 4 por 115 es 460 y se
recorre el punto decimal
me quedan 46 pesos o sea que voy a
ocupar 46 pesos del café de costa rica
ahora vamos a hacer lo mismo para saber
qué es lo que va a pasar con el café de
honduras para pensar el café de honduras
vamos a verlo aquí en honduras lo que
necesito es saber cuánto vale primero el
kilogramo de café de honduras el
kilogramo del café de honduras vale 80
pesos por lo tanto lo voy a apuntar aquí
el café de honduras vale 80 pesos por
kilogramo y de igual manera no voy a
ocupar un kilogramo entero lo que voy a
ocupar es 0.6 kilogramos de café de
honduras por lo tanto voy a
multiplicarlo por 0.6 que es lo que voy
a ocupar del kilogramo del café de
honduras y bueno kilogramos con
kilogramo se va
80 por punto 6 lo cual de 6 por 8 48 48
pesos entonces estos son 48 pesos y
ahora para saber cuánto va a valer la
mezcla de café de américa central pues
habrá que sumar 46 pesos más 48 pesos y
cuánto es esto y me quedan seis más
ochos 14 y llevamos una y entonces
ponemos de 11 44 es 9 entonces el café
de américa central
la mezcla de américa central debe de
costar 94 pesos y esa es mi respuesta